do you know if Jamie and Katie Holmes
are dating I have no knowledge of Jamie
okay at all I've never seen them
together I hate that this is blown up
like this and I feel like a lot is being
put on a three-second clip from you know
a podcast
do you like Katie Holmes for him he is
very happy with herself
okay they're dating yeah the crazy
Claudia chose her words very carefully
with me and wanted to be clear the
former Real Housewife of Atlanta cannot
confirm that Jamie Foxx and Katie Holmes
are a couple I don't have the knowledge
of this being back I don't I misspoke
despite the backtrack the story led the
talk today if you are dating they don't
want people to know don't put their
stuff out there in the street yeah I
think that person will be an ex best
friend now a new tabloid report claims
Jamie and Katie are on their way to the
altar and while that might be a stretch
multiple sources have told ET that
reports Fox and Holmes are dating are
correct I like to stay quiet you know
with anyone that I'm dating that I'm
really really dating that was Jamie on
dating in 2013 here's the timeline as we
know it I'm not up for this Tom Cruise
co-starred with Foxx in collateral in
2004 Tom and Katie started dating the
following year and split in 2012 Katie
and Jamie were first linked romantically
dancing together at a hamptons benefit
in 2013 Katie's team didn't respond to
our request for comment and Jamie's rep
told us no comment last year he
addressed the rumors with Nancy have you
very much in love yeah yeah all the time
but but but what I've learned about
society today is that they're so thirsty
especially in tabloid world and in
social media world
they're so thirsty to find any type of
story if I do fall in love
money you'll never know about